want to know what a dietitian looks for  in a good cookie I'll show you number  one not gluten free listen I'm so  grateful that we have a wide range of  gluten-free products out there for folks  who are Celiac or who are gluten  intolerant but I'm either of those  things and I can enjoy gluten without  issues and let's be real most  gluten-free cookies are dry as [ __ ]  number two  over crunchy I mean except if we're  talking Oreos because let's be real  that's always the exception also double  stuffed no question and most importantly  a cookie that I actually want to eat  listen I'm not eating cookies as health  foods if I'm gonna eat a cookie I'm  gonna eat the cookie that's really gonna  hit the spot oh  Mini Eggs  yes  please